this week on quadriga Mideast turmoil
the struggle for dominance in Yemen
iranian-backed Houthi rebels are under
attacked by a saudi-led coalition
observers call this latest conflict a
proxy war between Tehran and Riyadh the
two main regional powers are trying to
gain the upper hand in the Middle East
well Yemen be the next state to fall
apart Iran's close ally Syria has
already disintegrated four years of
civil war have devastated the country
millions of Syrians have fled the
Islamic state controls in large parts of
Syria and neighboring Iraq one thing is
certain the old regional order no longer
applies in the Middle East hello and
welcome to quadriga so is the shape of a
new order discernible or will it take
decades to emerge and what if anything
can stop the carnage and collapse in the
Middle East that's what we want to talk
about today with three people who follow
with events in the region very closely
it's my pleasure to welcome Emir Mousawi
he is the Berlin bureau chief of the
Iraqi TV channel you're a Kia TV
he's also reported for The Associated
Press in London and worked with both the
Iraqi foreign ministry and several NGOs
as a media consultant and we're very
glad to have Adnan Tabata be on the
program for the first time he's from
Iran and analyzes events there for
German and English media outlets he also
works as a consultant for the German
Foreign Ministry and lectures at the
[ __ ] China University in Dusseldorf and
finally Alan Posner is with us again he
was born in London is now based in
Berlin he's worked as an editor and
author for the German newspaper Deven
and was chief of commentary for Belgium
Sonntag and at present he contributes to
a variety of media among them the debate
magazine the European so Syria and Yemen
just two of the Middle Eastern countries
that appear to be in free fall and that
have become proxies for that age-old
rivalry between Iran and Saudi Arabia
Anan Tabata by many kind
trees in the Regency Iran as the winner
of the changes that have occurred since
the US intervention in Iraq would you
agree and what effect is that having on
the strategic aspirations in Tehran I
believe saying Iran is the winner does
imply that Iran has actively been trying
to bring things in this direction
whereas I think that it has been rather
the failure of some of the u.s.
strategies or US operations in the
region which may have ended up in in
favor of Iran's overall strategic
interests of course there is an
increasing self-confidence which at
sometimes leads to reasonable and
sometimes less reasonable statements by
Iranian officials but also to anxiety
among some of the regional actors and
this is what we are also observing these
days with the nuclear negotiations and
the anxiety that exists in some of the
regional powers and countries I mean
Mesabi that anxiety prompted Saudi
Arabia to intervene last week in Yemen
isn't it overreacting even Saudi
Arabia's good friends in Washington say
okay Iran may be giving some money to
the Houthi rebels in Yemen but that's
about it
well when we follow what saudi arabian
did in the last five years we will find
a main line that saudi arabian follow
what's what happen in in bahrain two
years ago that the saudis troops invade
bahrain and support the regime there it
is a kind of overreaction now what we
have what's happening in Yemen because
it's really there is no directive threat
on the security national security in
Saudi Arabia because Saudi Arabia
support Ali Abdullah Saleh in the past
they support also the Houthis in the
past and they support other also the
south via minutes and now the play is
coming in different rules
and I think in the end of the day that
Saudi Arabia is now risking with their
with their reputation in the
international war and the international
community also in the Arab and Muslim
community Saudi Arabia and other Sunni
Arab nations Alan Posner said that
they're going to band together to create
a forty thousand man's strong military
force how she seriously should we take
that move and do you think there's a
potential for these proxy wars to turn
into a direct hot conflict between Iran
and Saudi Arabia well I mean good luck
to them if they manage to put up a forty
thousand strong man army I mean
pan-arabism has never worked and I don't
think that pan soon ISM is going to work
so I'm very skeptical about that but I
but I would disagree with or Tamiya said
I think there is reason for the Sunnis
to be really worried in in the region if
you if you if you see this arc
stretching from Tehran via Baghdad via
Damascus to the Hezbollah and then in
Hamas in in on Egypt's borders and so
you you see and of course now Yemen you
see it from the Sunnis and Pope's
standpoint it must look like a Shia
ascension
led by led by Iran it must look like an
offensive and so now that's why they're
reacting this way will it lead to a sort
of civil war across the region either
well it's already happening isn't it and
it's happening from Lebanon 212 to
Tikrit to to wherever the question of
course if you look at that arc which nan
Tabata by he just told us was simply the
Iran making good use of opportunities
that arose in the region but if you look
at that arc it becomes threatening only
if you assume that Iran has malevolent
intentions the whole premise of the
nuclear negotiations being pushed by the
u.s. is that Iran can be
brought out of the cold back into the
community of nations and that its
behavior can change do you think that's
right a member type of sorry I I believe
that Iran of course has to be a very
constructive actor in the region as it
is a regional power whether we like it
or not and with the US withdrawal from
Iraq Iran has no choice but to be
constructive in Iraq as an Iraq is its
neighboring country and I think if we
for example get rid of this prolonged
nuclear file and all these discussion
around it it will be easier to actually
engage Iran and more meaningful manner
and not so much with coercive diplomacy
and say Iran you have to be more
responsible you have to be more
responsive but this one last point that
I would like to make in this regard is
that of course a constructive actor can
be as constructive as it is perceived to
be and of course we also have to think
about how has been policy been directed
to Iran in the past and whether Iran
could has been engaged as an as a
potential partner in the region I think
this has to be this is yet to happen I'm
sorry would you say that's right or does
that sound like a rather idealistic view
to you when you look at Iran well every
European policymaker
when he got a position or atmosphere
what the Iranian have now he will coming
in the conclusion that we should defend
our nation as they Iranian said and
using all these opportunities that
happened in the last five years in Iraq
in Syria and also in Yemen I think when
we when we look to the position of
Iranian from their position that we will
see a country surrounded from United
States troops for navigation in Iraq
there is some the Gulf states pushing on
Iranian economy and also having an
strong allies with their West and
Iranian stand
alone in this NFL and they should do
something to their national security and
I think this is a rational decision of
the Iranian coming back to the yard
point I think if we just put the ethnic
element of the conflict so neat and
sheet on the side and looking in the
whole conflict as alcohol we will find
every state in Arab countries and also
abroad and also Turkey trying to use
this new movement in Arab countries to
gain more benefit on their on their side
can I just stay with that for one moment
because this is something quite puzzling
about the situation in Yemen experts
tell us the Hootie's really haven't in
the past seen themselves primarily as
Shia they've seen themselves as a tribe
that it's a tribal kind of a division in
Yemen so what's going on why is this
suddenly being redefined in two terms
Shia Sunni well with it with a more
difference between what's happened in
Iraq with is when they gain more power
suddenly and what will compare it to
this situation with Houthis Houthis in
the end there are 25 percent of VMA
needs they are not really shi'ite but
they they consider themselves a part of
the Shia they have good manners and a
good sharing points with the Iranian
with the Shiites in Iran and in Iraq but
in the end of the day they are 20% 25%
of the human needs they gain a power
because they have agreement and allies
with their salah with what we call it
the bath ease of Yemen's they got the
know-how they have the military military
trained they know every corner of the
country 30 35 years they all over the
country and they gain and one allies and
this is the point this is the turning
point that the hope is become a power in
Yemen even al-qaeda is not able to face
them
in the ground I'm glad you mentioned
al-qaeda because many people say this
fight in Yemen Alan Posner is a
distraction from the truth a threat
there which is al Qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula it's got a strong foothold in
Yemen it's viewed as the most
threatening and adept of the various al
Qaeda affiliates would you say this
conflict is simply giving al Qaeda a
better opportunity in Yemen to establish
their yes but what but what are we
saying when we say that the point about
the region what's happened in the last
couple of years is the total
disintegration of state authority there
are no you can't can't make peace with
anybody because there's no state you can
make peace with you have to make deals
with non-state actors and I think that's
why people are so eager to make a deal
at least with Iran because Iran is a
stable state and the only other stable
state in the region the turkey and and
Egypt and but the whole Arabian state
all the Arabian state seems have
collapsed almost Libya to the west and
so on but if you ask how did that happen
that is very strongly because of Iranian
influence
why has Iraq disintegrated because the
Shia used their ascendency backed by
Iran to - to - to form basically a sheer
state impact at not a non-inclusive
state which gave is the possibility of
coming why is is so strong in in in
Syria because an Iranian backed regime
in in damascus would not negotiate so i
think you have to lay the blame fairly
firmly at the door of the people in in
in tehran i would disagree with you on
this point because if we follow the last
30 40 years what happened in arab
countries we will see whether it's soni
tashi it that there's a regimes to not
really represent the community there is
a dictatorship
press over the people for tears in the
end of the day my brother arm is a good
example they said okay we are not really
believing this call of state we should
looking for another model of state like
in Egyptian the Islam is there this is
the answer this is a movement what
happened in in in Libya and also this I
think we cannot blame just Iran it is
just a simply problem just we say I
think we state itself and that problem
the most important point here is I
really do not think there is one single
actor to blame for the whole mess or for
the chaos and I think that there is a
fair share for literally every regional
and global power and what happened in in
in Iraq and then additionally later in
in Syria and if you if you look at Iraq
and how the instability after the
overthrow of Saddam for which the
Iranians obviously has been have been
praying in order to to match your
perception of Iran they have been
praying for this therefore of course
that was a positive thing to happen and
what happened after that was basically
trying to make sure that the interests
of neighboring countries in Iraq are are
secured and that led to - yeah let's say
alliances that had ugly consequences but
this fight for maintaining their
interest under the banner of sectarian
LM Alliance has led to horrible
realities so the concept of sectarianism
as such was obviously fostered by those
who who were interested in power but
those ideas have unfortunately caused
some realities on the ground as well let
me come back to two points that Alan
Posner raised that also relate again to
Yemen so briefly staying with Yemen you
talked about the fact that most of the
Sunni Arab states have collapsed but of
course Saudi Arabia is in there fighting
hard now Allen told us a few moments ago
that he thinks Saudi Arabia well
might be overreaching with this attempt
to create an army and go into Yemen and
from what we heard from Emir we know
that the Hootie's they're tough they're
battle tested they've been in a number
of conflicts do you think Saudi Arabia
might have met a challenge here that it
can't master I would assume so because
actually the the realities on the ground
in Yemen there was a nice comment by a
colleague who said Yemen is the
Afghanistan of the Arab world so as to
say this is nestled in in a quagmire you
will enter into this battlefield which
is defined by local conflicts and there
is actually no way this invasion can end
in a better context than prior to it and
I think it was an instrument to show for
Saudi Arabia we are able to bring
together a coalition of of eight or ten
powerful countries in the region and
it's a very short-sighted initiative in
my point of view with no long-term
strategies behind it and that makes the
whole thing so dangerous and horrible
for the people in Yemen I mean Moussaoui
that makes me wonder why we are seeing
the US and Israel supporting this move I
asked Alan Posner about the possibility
that this will only make the threat of
al Qaeda in Yemen worse in fact we have
just seen a bombing in Yemen for which
Isis claimed attribution we hadn't seen
Isis in Yemen before they appear to be
establishing a foothold and some experts
tell us it looks like al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula is working with Isis
aren't we seeing a very dire expansion
of these two non-state actors on the
back of this conflict
I think the backup that gave from United
States and also from Israel as you said
for Saudi Arabia for their initiative
now in Yemen it gives more more power
and more more push and back up for the
al Qaeda and their members inside Yemen
to react their act
ability to gain more power to gain more
people they will they are going to argue
that look this is the unbelievables this
is the the westerns come to two would
like to invent invade us at the same the
same story that's happened in Iraq in
fact what they qaeda and is said in the
end and i think the conflict is going to
be it's going to be bigger than than
which we say especially if there's some
troops from saudi arabia coming to cross
the border through the yemen I think via
many the Houthis are really very well
trained of this kind of war against the
Saudis and I think Saudis would make a
big mistake if they send troops in Yemen
just six months ago the White House was
saying hey Yemen is a real model of what
we want to do in counterterrorism we've
got a two pronged effort we're using
remote drone strikes plus training on
the ground to make sure that we really
go for al Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula
well just about 10 days ago the US with
drawed it withdrew its its Special
Operations Forces from Yemen essentially
undermining that counterterrorism effort
well you know things happen right and
the United States hasn't been very
successful in I mean the Obama White
House has not been very successful in
any of its operations anywhere in the
Middle East extending the hand his hand
to Tehran didn't work supporting the
Muslim Brotherhood after they came to
power in Egypt didn't work the strike
against Libya didn't work so I'm not
really surprised that the the Yemen
operation didn't work there is no sense
anywhere over know of an overall
strategy from the White House they seem
to you know do one thing and then lose
interests and go out again so I'm not at
all surprised this doesn't work many
established yeah please do at least for
the for your outreach you mentioned to
Tehran I mean we are seeing 18 months of
a diplomatic Channel
between world powers permanent permanent
member states of UN Security Council
plus Germany and Iran going on with
intense talks last night for eight hours
from 9:00 p.m. to 5:30 a.m. with the
result of Iran's nuclear program being
at least freezed for the moment with
prospects of the long duration for an
agreement I think that at least is a
success story for this administration
which started this outreach before
president rouhani was was voted or
elected so therefore I mean at least
this part with with regard to the drone
campaigns I'm totally with you that they
have not been isn't is a containment and
a realpolitik approach to balance of
power also a strategy Tom Friedman who
is a well respected expert on the Middle
East said just this week he is perfectly
happy to see the White House simply
standing on the sidelines and trying to
stay out of these regional wars yeah
well I understand the reasoning behind
that there is no it it's it's an old
Imperial policy to do offshore balancing
it's what the what the so-called
realists Lobby in the United States has
always wanted its what the United States
did in in Europe before World War two
with results we've seen I just don't
think that the United States can do that
because the other powers aren't I mean
we know that Russia is backing Iran is
backing Damascus they is they're saying
that it's Russian pilots flying jets
against the rebels in in Syria because
they're not they don't trust Sunnis to
fly these jets anymore so and they and
they've promised
anti-aircraft rockets to to Iran so I
mean America can't stay out it's it's
it's an ideal I sort of I'll let them
plus it slightly cynical right let the
Sunni and Shiah let the Arabs kill each
other we're gonna stay out it's not
gonna work in a globalized world that
doesn't work I'm I'm sorry let's take
another example
it's been posed again and again the
could and should the US have done more
at a certain point in time to end the
Syrian civil war do you see a point in
these past five years where you would
have said the US should have acted very
very differently and they could have
brought the conflict to an end
definitely in truth in two times first
time in the beginning of the conflict of
Syria
I think United should at that time give
more attention of this conflict and they
could avoiding a lot of casualties and
this and they could find a channels to
to bring the parties of conflict in the
negotiation table I think this is this
was possible in the beginning so four
years later it was not possible the
conflict has really become bigger and
bigger and now the second chance I think
when Kerry said that we should talk with
the Machado I said I think Americans are
able now after this five years they have
the chance especially with the
negotiation with Iran but over what its
current cut could bring could bring
solution of this conflict between the
Iranian and American and think Americans
should do something in Syria conflict
because they are the only country able
to force the solutions like solution in
in Kosova
the last decade what's happened in the
end United States brought all the
parties in the table and they said sigh
Abbottabad by of course when we look at
the beginning of that conflict in Syria
we can realize how rapidly this collapse
has been occurring throughout the whole
region because it began on the back of
the Arab Spring and there was still a
lot of hope I think that rebel forces
there would gain the upper hand and that
it would bring a new era do you think
that the u.s. truly could have acted at
that moment in time to change things on
the ground even that belief given that
contact
I mean of course the the the the actors
back then the the the administration in
Tehran was a different one so we always
have to take that into consideration as
well obviously at the very beginning of
the conflict in in Syria there are
reports that from from the highest level
in Iran there was the the the the
suggestion for Bashar or the
recommendation to to introduce reforms
to not let this escalate and of course
then on each side there has been
mistakes assuming that the US it is in
the end again the u.s. who did not solve
this crisis I think that of course there
is a big share for the regional powers
there as well so I think that a more
constructive role and more engagement
with those influential powers would have
helped to not really let elevate because
this conflict started on a national
level that elevated to a regional level
then to a global level and before it
really escalated there could have been
different steps in retrospect it's easy
to say that but obviously and and
believing that a rebel group could
actually lead to a peaceful transition I
think we should really overcome this
this this idea because this is not going
to happen
and cozner do you think that if the
realpolitik camp is now in the
ascendancy in Washington we might see
some form of compromise with Bashar
Assad at least in the sense of perhaps a
transitional government that he might
still be a part of and could that be a
solution what I'm afraid they're in the
ascendancy the neo-cons have lost all
influence and I'm I don't think it's
gonna work this this kind of so-called
oil policy because the most unrealistic
thing you can imagine to go back to
Syria if the United States had hit
Bashar al Assad hard at the beginning
and forced him
militarily to negotiate before even the
groups were rebels before al Qaeda had
risen before there was even talk of is
then there might have been a grant I
mean it would have helped Turkey it
might have helped you run I don't know
if whether they really wanted Bashar
al-assad to did you see I think it could
have been saved and and and what's
happening now with this with this sort
of hold back will negotiate with
whoever's in power this will balance
this will balance that that is a 19th
century policy it's not going to work
let them negotiate with tell us very
concretely what you would want to see
the US and let's not leave Europe out of
this they're not doing a whole lot
better at projecting order and and
strategy into the region are they what
would you want to see the Western powers
doing in terms of a comprehensive
approach this in the space of five
minutes
yes well know who your friends are and
support them unreservedly that like if
they're in one sentence don't omit for
instance in the negotiations with with
with with Tehran
don't leave the Saudis and the Israelis
out in the cold don't give them the
impression that you're gonna make a deal
on their backs you can have you can make
a deal but don't do it over the heads of
the people who are your allies they may
be unsavory allies in the case of Saudi
Arabia and I'm not a friend of them so
on of this and so on but they are your
allies don't go above them for instance
just reinforce your friends and let your
enemies know that they are your enemies
and that you're going to give them hell
yeah yeah I agree actually to let's say
73% I don't like this idea of friends
and enemies I mean obviously in politics
you you you have no you have interests
only but for the sake of peace for the
sake of living the living conditions of
people you will have to create win-win
scenarios obviously you can for everyone
but I mean thinking about know who your
enemies are know who your friends are is
again this reduction to those who is I
mean is Saudi Arabia really a friend of
the United States so there is there's a
lot to debate or off the west so
integrate think think about how you can
support a coalition building in the
region do not emphasize the cleavages
rather think about how to to support the
idea of cooperation between those
countries
concrete example well I would actually
think of when you speak about Syria then
think about what is in fact if Iran's
realistic influence beyond the Bashar
Assad administration how can we work out
something that I think muga no no
there's more to to who's actually
proposing for Libya think about the
meaningful exit strategy and when you
think about the exit strategy you think
about those countries who have an
intimate knowledge of this context and
Iran obviously has intimate knowledge of
Iraq and Syria so integrate the actors
and as Alan Posner said speak to
everyone not just I mean in addition to
what you said speak to everyone not only
your friends we're told that a different
form of integration is already occurring
namely de facto military cooperation
we're told that that's coordinated for
example via the Iraqi government can you
confirm that I mean obviously this is
happening
but because that's the easiest thing
when you feel threatened by weapons or
by a bomb or by a tank it's easy to then
agree ok let's do something that that we
get less harmed so security and military
cooperation and intelligence exchange
that is happening but this is not
happening openly and this is a parallel
universe we want to get insight into but
I think this is going on and this can be
a first step I mean Moussaoui I know
you're working as a researcher on a
project called the transformation of the
Middle East
let's say that external powers continue
their their strategy of restraint of
holding back of doing containment at
most airstrikes military measures but no
comprehensive approach like the one Alan
Posner was was calling for what about
the regional powers what could ever
bring Iran and Saudi Arabia to a table
to cop talk about a comprehensive
coalition building strategy for the
region okay if we talking about this
question before Yemen and after Yemen
because this is the very important point
what's happened now in Yemen I could
argue that Iranian could be able to talk
with so
oh geez before Baja rain before Yemen I
could argue that Saudis could discuss
with Iranian about a plan for the region
after what before what's happened in
Iraq but nowadays the conflicts are
become so complicated between each part
that really it's very strong now
especially we see it now in the
discussion of the nuclear weapon that
Saudis and Israelis backing up pushing
for from other side of the disagreement
because they are not interested in and
in the end of the part this ethnic
conflict the element of ethnic conflict
in this Sunni turn sheet this bring more
fire more more benzene on the fire I
think in the end of the time that we
should give the people chance to decide
what they want to do I mean in Iraq in
the end of the day people decide to
choose their their leaders through
election this what did not happen in
Saudi Arabia this happened in Iran some
part of we cannot say this is a very
good democracy what happened in Iran but
at least there is a kind of changing in
the leadership of the Iranian but this
doesn't happen in in Saudi Arabia and
you told us know who your friends are
is Egypt our friend the US has just
given some very mixed messages to Egypt
apparently trying carrots and sticks
will that approach make Egypt and more
responsible player can we expect
anything from them well I think YouTube
is a very responsible player mr. Sisi I
think he has reasoned of course to
distrust the United States because they
supported mr. Morsi who admittedly was
an elected leader and who was deposed by
a military coup and that's not nice but
but mr. Morsi was also not a nice guy he
was
he will had dealings with Hamas and so
on and he was he was on the way to
become the kind of elected dictator we
know from Germany from our history and
so we know from Venezuela and other
places where so mister I think our cz
has has is on the best way to make Egypt
a very important player in the region
the stable player someone who wants an
inclusive government for Egypt and I
think that that the that that's one
country you know I'd say some most
important Arab country that's one
country United States really needs to
grapple to itself with hoops of Steel as
they say not let it drift away and and
and Turkey is another it's a stable
state and and it's absolutely necessary
for for for Syria and we've these are
the states we need to really rely on
there are old old allies of the West
they're not people who might go one way
might go the other you were arguing a
moment ago against a real politic
approach many people would say you've
just described one Turkey and Egypt
there's a lot of instability under the
surface there we're looking at two
countries with increasingly strong
authoritarian systems well true the
increase but Turkey let's face it is is
is a shining example of democracy
compared to every other country in the
region except for Israel so I mean come
on let's let's let's let's get real
about that in in in Iraq in Iran in the
end everything is decided by the Supreme
Leader now no matter what they say in
Parliament at the end is either either
he gets the stamp of approval from the
supreme leader or not so in we've talked
about Riyadh so Turkey and Egypt I say
well hey come on
so we're taping right now in the very
last stages of those negotiations of
about a nuclear agreement with Iran
let's say the supreme leader were
ultimately to agree to a deal
non-tibetan by looking at the overall
situation that the role of the regional
powers what would that do to the
geopolitics would it be a positive
game-changer or rather a rather
problematic one it would at least be a
positive first step which then of course
will depend on how Iran as an actor
behaves or how its policies will change
or not change how it is perceived by the
regional actors I think the main the
main point here is that resolving this
nuclear negotiations or resolving this
nuclear disparate would enable us to to
start meaningful processes to engage
Iran more meaningfully and therefore
also give Iran the constructive role it
has been demanding for so long so then
there is no big political issue in the
way to really engage Iran more
positively and I believe this is this is
why we all are hoping that once this
deal is agreed it will be sustainable
I mean Mousawi devil's advocates say if
there is a deal Saudi Arabia much like
Israel may only become more intransigent
saying they're gonna go for a bomb
whether you whether you believe it or
not so we're we're gonna need a bomb to
Saudi Arabia is that a possibility could
be for the short time if we have a deal
I think will they have more challenges
in the area and Middle East because the
parts of the conflict Israel and Saudi
Arabia they will see also Turkey they
will see this is a kind of a challenge
for them Iran become region power and
with a sign of United States this will
gain more instability in the region but
of a long term I think this will bring
more stability in the end of the day for
the situation for the relationship
between each country especially between
Iranian and the Gulf states when they
understand that is no threaten coming
from Iran as it new nuclear weapons I
think the long term will be very very
good for the region but in the end we
should facing the challenge in the short
term Alan Posner we heard a mimosa we
calling for internal changes in Saudi
Arabia saying that would be the one
thing that could
Saudi Arabia a more constructive player
Iran has a huge educated middle class
and we are often told that middle class
is quite sympathetic to the West if Iran
is brought in from the cold if Iran
becomes a part of the world trading
system again through the lifting of
sanctions might and we see real internal
change in that country that does make it
a more constructive player possibly but
I don't see any precedent for that
happening and and and you know this is
the European attitude you know let's
let's let's let's engage these people in
trade it's to talk to them and so on and
somehow this will change everything
never happened that way never happened
that way what we really need to do is to
tell the Iranian regime because those
are the people we're talking to is look
ok if we do get a deal on nuclear
weapons what what why do you need
missiles capable of hitting Athens and
Rome
why do you need why are you developing
long-range missiles capable of hitting
United States if you're if you're only
interested in in in in in peace and
security and blabber about why are you
doing this so you really need to keep
the that the pressure on these guys
because let's face it they are not
members of NATO they're not a member of
any sort of organization that we are
engaged in in in in security-wise
they are working against us so okay so
they decide not to build an atomic bomb
which they're not allowed to do anyway
right oh so that's a big deal
no now let's talk about your missiles
let's talk about your support for
Hezbollah let's talk about your support
for Hamas let's talk about you know your
support for revolutionary organizations
all over the let's talk you know for the
for the for Shia militias in Iraq I I
don't think that you know I think that
you definitely to keep the screws on
these guys I'll come to you one second
ever but at none is flying to Tehran
tomorrow so let's get him to address
some of those points as a proxy well I
think if you you you simply cannot look
at different Iranian activities in an
isolated fashion and I think it is I
wonder which country would negotiate
over how it may increase or not increase
its military capabilities or capacities
and I think it's obviously when you come
to the negotiating table and you agree
on something you have to make sure to to
continue talking you have to make sure
to come up with verification mechanisms
that make sure that that all sides and I
repeat all sides actually see no option
and non-compliance and that holds also
true for the the things that Iran has to
get in reverse which is first and
foremost sanctions relief so there needs
to be a strong UN Security Council
resolution ensuring that Iran which has
to then comply to ie to IAEA inspections
Iran abides to everything that is agreed
upon but at the same time a UN
resolution has to make sure that the
sanctions or the roadmap let's bring in
the word roadmap again the roadmap to
sanctions lifting is followed up in the
appropriate fashion
and I think this perception outlined by
my highly respected colleague with
supposin er is a bit we have to overcome
this idea let me I'm not choosing to
Sanders we don't have any moral and the
politic but we have a credibility if we
have you have to gain credibility of
United said you have should crush on
Iranian the same point pressure on the
Israelis coming back with Palestinians
to have an agreement in the end of the
day thank you very much to all of you
for being with us for this very complex
subject and thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in
see you soon bye-bye
you